nada
no no pero está bien que lo tenga
cerrado
qué tal oyentes o ciber seguidores de
radio canadá internacionales de su
programa canadá en las américas café o
el castor cibernético como le quieran
llamar están en sintonía de radio canadá
internacional desde los estudios de
radio canadá internacional aquí en la
ciudad de montreal un saludo muy grande
a todos los que nos escuchan por nuestro
sitio internet www.state.gov por
facebook live les damos la más cordial
bienvenida en el menú de la semana les
tenemos educación elecciones y bueno ya
les diremos porque antes que eso saludo
a mis colegas como están leonardo firmen
o luis laborda como les digo estamos
ahora
bueno vamos a la otra
en el programa de hoy les presentamos
claro como siempre los reportajes y los
temas que nos interesaron más durante la
semana van persie los mensajes
[Aplausos]
tenemos una carpeta llena de mensajes de
nuestros oyentes y ciber seguidores no
se quería preguntarles antes de pasar de
lleno con una entrevista especial que
tenemos en el programa de hoy si hubo
algún tema que les llamó la atención en
la semana algunas noticias y sorprenden
de no yo sigo una buenísima pero ya les
voy a decir la semana pasada
algún oyente en facebook que me lanzó
así como una
tipo de concurso para ver quién me
conseguí a un tratamiento capilar porque
cuando estoy de costado
[Risas]
no no pero me llamó la atención porque
el nivel de detalle yo no sabía que eso
se veía tanto la iluminación es
sumamente bien y para nada
que me haya llamado la atención lo único
que me llamó la atención en las últimas
24 o 48 horas es el retorno in
tempestuoso del calor así que no se
había abandonado durante un tiempo unos
escasos días pero que fue suficiente
como para ella empecé a extrañarlo y
sobre todo sabiendo que bueno quedará
más o menos un mes como para que
empiecen a llegar las temperaturas bajas
de verdad aunque hay ya que nos quejamos
siempre cada año durante todo el
invierno
hay que reconocer que este año el verano
ha sido al menos generoso bastante
bastante extenso y las temperaturas han
sido más que elevadas en algunos casos
realmente insoportables igual cuando uno
empieza a dar cuenta de que los días se
empiezan a cortar y que en las noches de
alfresco es bastante más intenso que
otros momentos es como la frase de la
película matrix es the sound of
inevitable t el sonido de la
inevitabilidad como hemos dicho muchas
veces hay que recordar también perdón
hay que recordar también que
por ejemplo en el invierno aquí yo
siempre digo lo mismo a pesar de lo frío
que es a pesar de la nieve a pesar del
hielo etcétera es verdad que el invierno
es un invierno bastante luminoso y mucha
luz mucha lucha y mucho sol y el sol es
muy fuerte muy intenso cuando estuve en
moscú una de las cosas que más me
impactó allá y que en algún momento me
afectó incluso físicamente fue lo corto
que es el día y lo juro que es lo gris
ya que lo gris que es en invierno igual
el tema de cuando hay mayor día más
cuando el sol está más presente cuando
es un día súper despejado son los días
más fríos
no lo que yo quería decir es que el
calor volvió aquí a montreal pero vieron
las noticias sobre el oeste canadiense
nevó estuvieron con temperaturas bajo
cero la ciudad de edmonton hemos estado
aquí estamos en pleno verano y allá está
nevando y entonces tenemos al mismo
tiempo en la misma época del año estamos
en septiembre
temperaturas más altas que las que
deberíamos tener por aquí deberíamos
andar como 'los por los 20 grados
exactamente bueno comencemos ahora
nuestro programa ya en serio
con un poco de educación en tiempos de
campaña electoral
[Música]
hola soy daniel años garcía pianista
colombiano que vive en montreal trabajo
con los ensambles la machine y el
ensamble oyen y los invito a vivir
canadá en las américas café la radio
canadá internacional en la web
ya lo decíamos la semana pasada cuando
tuvimos aquí en el estudio alejandra
saga méndez candidata por la
circunscripción de braza sube en el
norte de montreal que la juventud se
implica poco en las elecciones menos de
lo que se desearía por muchos para
cualquier democracia sin embargo en
elecciones muy reñidas como la de barack
obama en 2012 o como la de andrés lópez
andrés manuel lópez obrador en mexico
los jóvenes salieron a votar pero
motivarlos parece que no es tan fácil
hay que tiene que estar en un contexto
muy particular para que los jóvenes
quieran salir a votar yo no estoy de
acuerdo con esa apreciación votar o no
votar no es la única forma de caminar en
política y los jóvenes participan de
muchísimos modos que no tienen que ver
necesariamente con el simple hecho de
votar lo que se viene ahora
si participan claro de hecho aquí en
montreal o vimos aquí en quebec lo vimos
en 2012 los jóvenes se manifestaron con
esta con lo que se llamó la primavera
en la que los jóvenes los estudiantes
manifestaron su defendieron su derecho a
tener una educación de calidad una
educación que fuera accesible etc
entonces si los jóvenes implican de
muchas maneras pero en el en el marco
digamos de elecciones provinciales que
es el actual en ganado comisión
exactamente que hay con elecciones
pronto en nuevo brunswick y elecciones
aquí en la provincia de québec nos
parece importante hablar con de este
tema de la de la participación juvenil o
de la de los jóvenes sí con una
motivadora la democracia por excelencia
se llama mónica rosales ella es
coordinadora de los programas de
educación a la democracia por elecciones
quebec bienvenida a que nada en las
américas mónica como ésta la tenemos por
skype la vemos cómo está hola a todos
muy bien muchas gracias gracias por
acompañarnos cuando hablamos de los
programas que organiza elección
elecciones quebec para digamos motivar a
los jóvenes a implicarse en las
elecciones
qué nos referimos qué tipo de programa
si usted es proyecto proyectos trabajan
ustedes si paloma imagínate que
normalmente la gente asocia elecciones
que beck a la organización de las
elecciones y efectivamente está en el
corazón de nuestra misión pero
elecciones que make también se ocupa por
ejemplo de todo el seguimiento del
financiamiento político de asegurar los
derechos electorales a todos los
quebequenses y hay un mandato que es
menos conocido que es la promoción de
valores de democráticos así que aunque
nosotros trabajamos para la
participación electoral
entendemos que el hecho de votar empieza
antes y sigue después del gesto del voto
así que trabajamos muchísimo
antes de la campaña a promover
experiencias positivas de democracia con
los jóvenes que aún no tienen la edad de
votar por ejemplo así que la gran parte
de nuestros programas están dirigidos a
niños en la escuela en el colegio en la
escuela primaria secundaria o un poco
más tarde
el college y tenemos diferentes
programas que son realmente muy
interesantes y que permiten a los
jóvenes tomar conciencia de
de lo que significa la participación de
lo que significa comprometerse con la
comunidad de tercera
entonces ejemplos tenemos un programa
muy interesante que se llama vox populi
to democracia en la escuela o mixto
pileta de monjas y alcohol
en que trabajamos conjuntamente con la
asamblea nacional de québec y a través
del cual damos apoyo a los colegios de
primaria y de secundaria en toda la
provincia para formar consejos de
estudiantes no sé si ustedes pero en
quebec los colegios sobre todo de
secundaria tienen que formar un consejo
de estudiantes a la imagen de la
democracia pública y nosotros los
acompañamos para que ese proceso sea lo
más positivo posible porque a veces
pueden convertirse más como en consejos
de vida estudiantes hemos de organizar
las fiestas del colegio no la las avalan
tienen navidad y es importante es en el
colegio pero también es importante que
yo se reconozcan como actores de cambio
que pueden llevar la voz de sus colegas
estudiantes
por ejemplo un consejo la administración
del colegio o al administrador a los
dirigentes del colegio debe ciertamente
y es muy positivo porque cuando hay un
consejo estudiante que es democrático
que es abierto que promueve proyectos
hay enseguida con como decir hay
consecuencias positivas para colegios a
los jóvenes se sienten realmente
miembros de esta comunidad y son
orgullosas de participar que podría
hablarles horas de los ejemplos de
consejos de estudiantes un poco en todo
que ve y vamos por todo te beca' porque
es vasto y hemos estado en comunidades
por ejemplo indígenas hemos estado en el
norte más norte en el sur más sur
como colombiano he tenido que aprender
muchísimo de geografía que viven en
pueblos para saber cómo cómo llegar y
porque la realidad son muy diferentes
también y las tallas de los colegios y
cómo se organizan son ustedes los que
van a escuela por escuela son ustedes
los que plantean esto son las escuelas
las que piden para tener este tipo de
procesos es como de parte y parte sanz
nosotros ofrecemos el programa hacemos
la promoción del programa a través de
estrategias normales no de contactar con
los directores de las escuelas con las
comisiones escolares etcétera pero
realmente el gesto lo tiene qué
y lo tiene que hacer el colegio y el
encargado del consejo de estudiantes
games live su colegio participar en el
programa que es gratuito y una vez que
esté incierto el programa tiene acceso
al material pedagógico de apoyo etcétera
estos tenemos un sitio web donde todas
las publicaciones los talleres son
disponibles y además la gente puede
tomar la decisión de llamarnos para
pedir una formación y tenemos un equipo
de formadores tanto aquí en el ex acb
como en asamblea nacional que van a
desplazarse directamente a la escuela
ahora mi hija no sé si es el caso si son
ustedes quienes organizan eso pero mi
hija participó en una votación
recientemente en las últimas elecciones
municipales mi hija en su escuela
participó como votante fueron a mis
hijos los dos fueron a votar por sus
puntos de vista con respecto por sus a
sus preocupaciones más que por un
candidato por sus preocupaciones en el
barrio que si querían más juegos en el
parque que si querían más visitas
disponibles entonces fueron y
participaron es parte del proyecto
proyectos
es hacer si efectivamente se llama el
electorado como aprendices electores
diríamos
este programa electoral tiene diferentes
como niveles de aplicación no hay uno de
que de que tú hablas paloma es un nuevo
o un nuevo proyecto de lectura negativa
e invita a las familias a vivir la
democracia en familia no sé si ustedes
lo han vivido pero cuando vamos a votar
muchas papas llevamos a nuestros hijos
para enseñarles lo que estamos haciendo
porque lo hacemos porque es importante
para nosotros etcétera y hay otros
también que los llevan porque no tienen
más opciones porque no hay en niñera o
no los pueden dejar en el colegio o lo
que sea pero lo que sentimos es que es
un compromiso común la democracia así
que si hay papás que quieren vivir esa
experiencia con los hijos pensamos que
sería importante ofrecerles la
oportunidad de vivirlo hasta el final
así que en estas elecciones próximas
en todos los centros de voto de quebec
va a haber un pequeño una pequeña mesa
de votación para los niños
y como tú dices paloma cuando fueron las
elecciones municipales en montreal y
sismos un convenio como tal que quería
vivirlo porque hicimos un test el dos
elecciones parciales provinciales y una
de ellas era en la región de montreal y
la ciudad estaba muy interesada en eso y
luego hicimos un convenio para
adquisiciones
en principales
pero ahora va a ser realmente en grande
así que no importa dónde están en quebec
los papás van a poder llevar a sus hijos
con ellos el día del voto y lo que les
pedimos a los papás es que hablen
justamente de la importancia de ese
gesto así que los niños van a ver en él
el modelo del papado de mamá o de sus
abuelos o de sus tíos de la persona con
la que vayan y al final si quieren vivir
lo van a poder hacerlo donde entonces
van a tener un boletín de voto van a
tener un
van a poder ir a ejercer ese pequeño
gesto
obviamente no por los candidatos porque
sería un poco irresponsable no se hace
en ese mismo momento así que es una
pregunta de orden democrático que en
esta vez la pregunta va a ser porque es
piensas tú que es importante votar y
bueno y hay varias opciones que ellos
van a poder escoger ese es el boleto ese
es el como del proyecto para los más
pequeños en los saltos de voto pero
electora cne ofrece también una
simulación electoral para las escuelas
con más grandes en secundaria o al final
de la primaria también en los centros
juveniles en los que la persona que
trabaja con los jóvenes el profesor o el
animador comunitario etcétera va a tener
acceso a material de preparación al voto
para comenzar a mostrar los jóvenes cómo
funciona realmente la democracia donde
busca la información como como
informarse adecuadamente etcétera y
ellos si van a votar por los verdaderos
unidades de la circunscripción
obviamente no es un voto que cuenta para
la decisión pero para poder permitirles
a ellos también verse en relación a los
adultos
como botones y construcciones con mi
escuela y como votaron mis papás por
ejemplo este es como la otra parte de
electoral ya yo creo volver un poco lo
que debatimos al comienzo antes de
iniciar el diálogo con nuestra
entrevistada y preguntarle a ella
entonces en base a esa experiencia en
base a ese recorrido que hacen de ese
vasto territorio como lo definió ella
misma de la provincia de québec cuál es
la respuesta que recibe si los jóvenes y
los niños que también forman parte de
esta experiencia realmente se interesan
en el acto comicial
yo nunca dejo de sorprenderme las
reacciones de los jóvenes de los niños
es tan positiva cuando hicimos el test
yo yo estuve en montreal en la
circunscripción del wine viviéndolo en
cada uno de los centros de voto los
niños están tan orgullosos y tan felices
de vivir lo es es muy muy muy positivo
realmente pero es positivo también para
las familias para la gente que está en
el centro de voto no diría que con la
energía positiva en cuanto a los
colegios tenemos tantos testimonios de
papás de profesores de jóvenes que
tienen
muchas ganas de poder votar finalmente
por un voto que cuente no para elegir a
luz a nuestros diputados así que el el
recibimiento de este tipo de programas
es muy positivo
yo creo que falta mucha más sección de
este tipo nosotros hacemos nuestra parte
pero trabajamos mucho en colaboración
con diferentes organismos de jóvenes
comunitarios ongs hay muchos programas y
hay lugar para trabajar la participación
no solamente electoral sino la
participación ciudadana desde diferentes
ángulos yo sí quería preguntarle en
relación con esto mismo le decíamos al
principio que vivió su primavera de arce
en 2012 donde los jóvenes se defendieron
mucho sus derechos por la educación ht y
se manifestaron de manera monstruosa
diría yo en las calles de la ciudad de
montreal desde entonces usted ha visto
una mayor implica hacer una evolución
digamos en la implicación de los jóvenes
en la política y en la iii en las
elecciones mismas
ustedes hablaban al principio que es la
realidad que los jóvenes votan menos es
una realidad no solamente en quebec en
canadá sino en todas en todas las en
todos los lugares del mundo digamos un
movimiento mundial sin querer entrar en
los detalles de lo que dice la
investigación o los investigadores
sabemos que si hay un cambio
generacional y que para los jóvenes
quizás el voto no tiene la misma
no quiero decir importancia porque no es
eso pero no tiene como el mismo
significado que quizás tenía para
nosotros o para nuestros abuelos o para
las antiguas generaciones los jóvenes
efectivamente buscan otras maneras de
implicarse y encuentran en causas como
por ejemplo el medio ambiente o la
alimentación responsable
otros temas se encuentran hay una
insatisfacción y una es una forma
concreta de realizarse de participar y
yo creo que está bien que lo hagan
que no se traduzca en el voto es un
problema no lo podemos negar porque
finalmente la democracia es una
democracia representativa y si los
jóvenes no ejercen su derecho al voto de
alguna manera la visión que ellos pueden
tener a la sociedad no va a estar
representada
ha habido una evolución hay más jóvenes
que participan en consejos de
administración por ejemplo candidatos y
candidatas o incluso consejeros por
ejemplo de la ciudad los diputados que
han sido elegidos es suficiente no es
suficiente y trabajamos para que eso se
haga de todas maneras desde elecciones
quebec
nosotros no tenemos como toda la no es
nuestra responsabilidad única es muy
importante que ustedes por ejemplo
periodistas hablen del tema y que los
mismos partidos políticos también hablen
del tema que sea un trabajo conjunto
digamos para que los jóvenes se sientan
como implicados en el proceso de las
gracias mónica rosales le vamos a
agradecer mucho por haber participado en
este en este programa con nosotros
creemos que con todas esas explicaciones
que nos dio y los ejemplos que nos
presentó también los jóvenes que nos
estén escuchando que nos vayan a
escuchar en los próximos días porque el
programa se queda por ahí en el en el en
los internet como les diste podrán estar
más convencidos de la importancia de
votar no solo como usted dice la
democracia se hace de varias partes y
una de ellas es la votación entonces
muchas gracias mónica rosales usted es
coordinadora de programas de educación a
la democracia en el organismo público
elecciones quebec que está justamente
muy activo porque las elecciones aquí en
quebec se vienen para el 1º de octubre
muchas gracias gracias a ustedes que
tengan una linda tarde al 20 entonces
hasta luego
[Música]
hola mi nombre es exclusivo soy chileno
vigón toronto y soy dramaturgo de la
compañía alamedas tierra company y los
invito a escuchar canadá en las américas
café el programa de radio canadá
internacional en la web
[Aplausos]
y yo sé rato les dije que les iba a
hablar de una noticia que me sorprendió
a mí si julio olvide presentarse
presentarles mi noticia resulta ser que
un señor cuyo nombre es mi mail y
bélgica
dos veces me el giner se ganó
se ganó dos veces la lotería mi próximo
jorge jorge jorge en cinco meses de
jorge en el espacio de cinco meses e
igual yo sé escuché que hay más
probabilidades de ganar dos veces la
lotería que ganarla una vez que se la
gana una vez tiene más problemas
probabilidades de ganar la de nuevo que
uno que no la ganó ganarla una vez me lo
puede repetir por favor pero cuál es
pero cómo funciona esa empresa pero no
sé hay más probabilidades de carecer de
un avión que ganar la lotería también
tiene más probabilidades una vez que
tienes un accidente puedes tener varios
más he visto eso gente que tiene un
accidente después tiene mucho porque eso
es un distraído
mira las noticias que hablan de un
un rasgo que cada dos veces en el mismo
árbol que dicen que no que no pasa y si
para este señor es muy feliz y feliz
simplemente feliz dos veces en cinco
meses se ganó la lotería y se llama dos
veces me el cid méxico y bueno fue a
cobrar lo nombraron vino vieron el
nombre no todo una vez le pagaron
nuevamente le volvieron a pagar y así
ganó de verdad dos veces con números
diferentes tiene mucha suerte no tiene
muchísimo que nos diga cómo hace por
favor me limito a mentir por favor es de
winnipeg de la provincia de manitoba así
que tendremos tal vez quiera ver como
como el otro en 20 dólares
[Música]
es repetir esta semana de otros 22 que
viene otros 20 dólares y si en algún
momento que quieren empezar a llegar a
un cerdito atrás y guarde 20 sean 200
nos vamos a quejar bueno les queremos
recordar a nuestros oyentes que nos
nominaron si nos nominaron a los premios
latinos canadá 2018 dentro de la
categoría web programa web programa
radio o televisión web y nos nominaron
entonces estamos muy contentos y bueno
claro si alguien quiere votar por
nosotros de los que nos escuchan en
canadá no nos vamos a quejar contento
exacto de la historia es que hay dos
maneras diferentes de participar en
realidad la participación es la misma
uno puede ir al sitio de internet de
estos premios y votar en el sitio de
internet y una sola vez pues una sola
vez tiene que ver con la decisión de la
computadora
y después es esa cantidad de votos valen
por un cierto porcentaje y después una
comisión evaluadora evalúa no quiere
decir que porque nos voten los dos
millones de espectadores que tenemos hoy
vamos a ganar número ayuda así que si
quieren ir entonces latin awards premios
latinos awards sí o latin awards canadá
punto sea latin awards
punto o sea se dice nominados y en la
sección categoría web estamos nosotros
entonces bueno por ahí se lo recordamos
a nuestros oyentes y otra cosa es que
esta semana estuvimos trabajando en
temas que nos interesaron a todos y
tenemos muchos temas que presentarles
pero les dije que escogieran uno
los escoger sólo un momento y una estoy
en la distancia horrible con lente novio
sin lentes tampoco tengo aquí y saludos
de milán abril dice saludos de cappelle
los estoy escuchando con mi cuñada que
está aquí de vacaciones y que es de
uruguay
la cuñada entonces todas las cuñadas
particularmente uruguay por ejemplo
emilio m a dice saludos a ti si alguien
cuba pablo como es barrios a ese lo
conozco algún lado 16 2 a todos de este
lado y del otro lado el micrófono un
abrazo y yo quiero decirle emilio
perdonen que pablo casi viene pero que
no vino que casi vino y no vino y
leonardo nicolás emanuel rayman le dice
saludos desde argentina así que saludos
a todos esos que nos están viendo por
seguir y que se sumen cada vez más
estamos prendí el vendiendo el teléfono
estamos aprendiendo el teléfono
justamente la difusión por facebook lite
discúlpenme pero presenten me sus
reportajes porque sé que luis estuvo
trabajando particularmente en el tema de
la inmigración que suena muchísimo en la
campaña electoral y es un tema de
campaña efectivamente es un tema que
está siempre presente en la sociedad
pero que toma también otro valor un
valor distinto tal vez un valor en
particular en época de campaña todos los
candidatos están hablando de esta
cuestión cada uno sabrá si lo satisface
o no la propuesta de los distintos
candidatos pero al margen de esta
cuestión en el marco de la campaña
electoral
días pasados pudo conocerse uno del
relevamiento que es el banco de
desarrollo de canadá el bdc con un
relevamiento sobre la contratación que
las empresas en el país hacen de la mano
de obra inmigrante y lass
los resultados de esa encuesta fueron
realmente preocupantes porque entre
otras cosas dicen que el 18 por ciento
de las empresas
está dispuesta a contratar trabajadores
formados en el extranjero 18 por ciento
pero dentro del universo de empresas que
existen en el país el 57 por ciento es
decir prácticamente dos tercios un
poquito menos y rechaza de plano la
contratación de inmigrantes están más
dispuestos a contratar
mano de obra menos calificada jóvenes a
los que tengan que formar retirados
personas retiradas se jubilarán
exactamente o incluso contratar gente y
no tienen ningún conocimiento del med y
en particular del que se trate y
formarlos desde cero antes que contratar
mano de obra inmigrante y explican por
qué bueno dicen a grosso modo que hay
reticencia lizzy sanamente es la
reticencia puede ser leída de distintas
maneras por supuesto una de esas
lecturas es una actitud de tipo racista
y otras lecturas de desconocimiento por
esa la base yo creo que es la ignorancia
el desconocimiento de lo que es
diferente de uno sí y él y el director
general de la cámara de comercio
latinoamericana en quebec héctor giraldo
está de acuerdo en que el reticencia de
parte de las empresas a contratar mano
de obra inmigrante y cuando hablamos de
mano de obra inmigrante estamos hablando
inmigrantes que residen en el país no
estamos hablando de traer gente desde
afuera hay gente que ya está aquí que
tiene su estatus legal en el país en el
profesor
fue seleccionada y en muchos casos fue
seleccionada por su actividad por su
profesión y en algunos casos también
lleva ya tiempo viviendo aquí es decir
que conoce las costumbres conoce las
normas comienza a adaptarse dices que ya
no está adaptada a la sociedad él
sostiene que esta reticencia está basada
principalmente en la mala información
whelan desinformación por parte de las
empresas sostiene giraldo que hay una
gran cantidad de recursos que están
disponibles para las empresas que
quieren contratar mano de obra
inmigrante recursos de distinto tipo que
tiene que ver con cuestiones de
financiamiento que tiene que ver con
cuestiones de formación profesional que
tiene que ver con asistencia a la
realización de procesos de adaptación de
la formación mejor dicho de capacitación
o capacitación de los profesionales
trámites que sabemos que a veces son
engorrosos etcétera pero el secreto está
en que muchísimas de estas empresas ni
siquiera saben que todos esos recursos
están disponibles entonces el de
reconoce a los autores
a las distintas administraciones que han
pasado por el gobierno el haber puesto a
disposición esas herramientas pero les
crítica el no haber difundido
suficientemente la existencia de esas
herramientas y señala que lo que está
faltando es un agente mediador entre las
empresas y los recursos para que diga
miren ustedes necesitan esto distribuir
a la ncaa no tienen que vengan a
buscarlos yo los ayudo yo los he ido yo
los acompaño y también por supuesto dice
que las empresas deben abandonar su
postura su posición cómoda y salir a
buscar los apoyos que necesitan ahora
también hay mucha desinformación como
dices no solamente con respecto al
proceso de de atraer o de ir a buscar
inmigrantes sino también se escuchan
muchos muchos de los de los políticos en
esta campaña electoral particularmente
dicen dicen cosas rápido y entonces la
gente retiene únicamente lo que se dice
rápidamente entonces si escuchamos a uno
que otro de los candidatos que ha dicho
los inmigrantes no hablan francés por
supuesto que si tú eres un empresario no
quieres ir a buscar a los inmigrante
es porque piensas que no hablan francés
y que no van a poder cumplir con los
requisitos antes teníamos un invito a
que nos hablaba de la formación
democrática para jóvenes y niños y yo
pensaba mientras ella hablaba no lo
sugerí porque era sacarla de tema por
supuesto y no es cuestión de ella sería
muy bueno tener una iniciativa similar
para formar a los políticos en la
democracia exactamente porque muchas
veces se echan mano herramientas que no
son ilícitas ni lógicas y muchas veces
eso tiene un desconocimiento sobre los
temas que abordan que a mí me deja con
la boca abierta porque a veces dicen
rápidamente por ejemplo que los
inmigrantes que 50% 58 por ciento de los
inmigrantes recién llegados no hablan
francés pues no es clara es normal de
estar llegando al país hay un tiempo de
adaptación aunque hayas tomado cursos de
francés en tu país tienes que comenzar
aún no es lo mismo hasta cuando uno va
tuvo que ser un proceso normal entonces
creo que eso asuste 58 pero si uno
quiere saber cuánto de estos políticos
saben por ejemplo
quienes han sido elegidos por quebec
para venir aquí porque hayan certificado
yunque de selección de quebec que ayuda
después al proceso que se realiza a
través de la embajada a quienes pasan
por el proceso de selección de las
representadas distintas representaciones
de quebec en en distintas partes del
mundo deben pasar por una entrevista que
la tienen que hacer en fianza con cursos
de francés
y son ofrecidos a distancia los hacen
por internet y todo si existe ese
proceso pero parece que es algunos de
los candidatos no lo saben y si no tiene
uno las lenguas oficiales o algunas de
ellas son las dos bajas de puntuación
claro no beber punto exacto entonces ahí
es una cuestión de acumulación de puntos
cuando eres aceptado o no como
inmigrante residente bueno entonces es
un tema interesante que pueden ver en
nuestro sitio internet el título es
abundan recursos para que las empresas
contraten a inmigrantes de luís labor
tema que podríamos debatir durante horas
la sugestión que yo tengo es para el
próximo debate invitamos a nosotros
para thelma ese fue el comentario de una
de las invitadas a hacer las preguntas a
los a los candidatos a la elección de
quebec que fue ayer perfecto entonces
muy graciosa su respuesta no lo entendí
jo
le preguntaron y ya le clarificaron su
su duda y le dijo patel man y eso quiere
decir no para nada aunque leonardo tú
estuviste preparando un reportaje entre
otros sobre marihuana
marihuana y sobredosis parece que me
interesa demasiado
me preocupa porque se viene
mentalidad y resulta que bueno salió un
artículo en cbc en el sitio internet se
dice que habla de
se pueden morir de la planteaba la
pregunta se pueden morir por sobredosis
de cannabis bueno presenta la mente no
no hay nadie en el mundo hasta el día de
hoy que hayan muerto por sobredosis de
canal que el cannabis haya provocado
algo en el cuerpo de la persona y haya
tenido un accidente o haya provocado un
accidente de amor son dos cosas
distintas pero hemos terminado con
alcohol o que otras cosas exacto
entonces no se puede ellos plantean la
discusión de que no se puede hablar si
bien han aumentado los casos de gente
que llega a las urgencias con problemas
de la gestión
de consumo de cannabis no hay ninguno
que en realidad directamente gracias a
ese efecto peligre su vida entonces
hablan de que están mal utilizado el
término sobredosis y que podría
utilizarse por ejemplo el término que se
utiliza en el en el terreno de la cal
del consumo de alcohol es envenenamiento
por alcohol
está bien pero en realidad hay ciertos
médicos que hablan
de qué se trata y cuáles son las
evidencias de que esto puede llegar a
pasar y en realidad hasta ahora
científicamente no hay probado que haya
ninguna persona que haya fallecido por
esto y está los responsables de este
estudio están directamente en contacto
con la gente de colorado en estados
unidos que fue el estado que legaliza el
generoso primero la marihuana y que van
así evidentemente ellos dicen que los
primeros dos años hubieron casos se
registraron un montón de casos de gente
que tenía se presentaba la urgencia por
el consumo de marihuana pero no
necesariamente que tengan problemas de
salud si alucinaciones ataques de pánico
pero no es algo que pueda llegar a ser
físicamente psico es considerado
sobredosis dato exacto no porque el
digamos el alcohol en sangre
proporcional si uno comete más alcohol
en un momento dado pueden haber ciertos
órganos que dejen de funcionar en el
caso del de la marihuana no uno puede
volverse en todo caso loco
y es justamente eso un pequeño artículo
sobre la discusión entre si se puede
llamar sobredosis a lo que uno tiene
después de consumir mucha marihuana
ahora justito que se viene la que viene
que va a ser más accesible para la gente
ahora hay que decirlo también que la
legalización no es para cualquier
persona igual hay que tener una cierta
edad y hay que una ciertos lugares
garantía está regulada regular y también
está bastante regula bastantes lagunas
también claramente sobre toda la
cuestión médica porque no hay casos que
no tienen casuística para decir esto
puede pasar o esto no entonces están
todos a la espera de qué es lo que va a
pasar el 19 de octubre van a estar las
llenas de gente las emergencias tengo
que parar ahí porque si no no alcanza el
tiempo de leer
el programa y si tengo que hablar
mis temas pero no tenía miles de temas
pero escogí intentar
pero me di cuenta que esta semana hablé
hubo un tema que me interesó
particularmente que son las mujeres los
talentos de mujeres latino canadienses
porque hice tres entrevistas con tres
mujeres maravillosa fijación total
fijación total porque una chica muy
joven una soprano latino canadiense
andrea núñez está presentándose ahora a
partir de mañana el 15 con la ópera de
montreal es muy jovencita y está
iniciando su carrera operística con la
ópera de montreal después también
entreviste a una lingüista argentina que
es argentina pero vive aquí desde hace
muchísimo tiempo y ahora se ha vuelto
especialista en una lengua indígena
canadiense y escribió un libro de
gramática de esta lengua que es el clic
de mus de una zona del norte de ontario
y hablé con otra mujer que es madeleine
cristina caguas que hizo una
investigación sobre los los y las
trabajadoras latinas en el medio
comunitario de toronto entonces me di
cuenta que me interesaron es un solo
tema ya lo decidí con tres mujeres pero
un solo tema el talento femenino la al
mono que nadie mostró el capítulo eso es
realmente un problema para mí puedo
contarles a ustedes mientras estaba
hablando
este que estoy mostrando es justo uno de
los temas argentinas que se especialista
en la lengua indígena canadiense y que
se llama jimena terraza y jimena tienen
20 años viviendo aquí en canadá y
comenzó interesándose en las lenguas
indígenas de la argentina y poco a poco
se dio cuenta que quería interesarse en
las lenguas indígenas de canadá
y se volvió especialista no habla la
lengua indígena canadiense del crit de
mus no lo habla pero sí fue capaz con su
formación de lingüista de crear un libro
de gramática increíble increíble
entonces en esta entrevista ya nos
cuenta sobre eso y bueno las otras dos
chicas una que vive en toronto sobre los
trabajadores comunitarios es muy
interesante su investigación porque se
da cuenta que los latinos y las latinas
nos implicamos
mucho o se implican mucho en el medio
comunitario y hacen cambios dentro de la
sociedad desde la base entonces antes de
conocer a los candidatos a todos estos
inmigrantes que no me parece como que no
los conocen en conocimiento no entonces
bueno estamos contribuyendo y nosotros
también contribuimos oporto oigan saben
que nos llegamos a leer si un un
poquitito vamos a leer un poquitito
[Música]
entonces quien quiere comenzar pues yo
tengo aquí un mensaje que dice la visión
y generosidad de johana botero creadora
de enfermeras en canadá y dice hola cuál
es el límite de edad para aplicar como
enfermera en rea no hay un límite de
edad para aplicar a ninguna profesión en
canadá lo que hay que hacer es pasar los
exámenes pertinentes esa orden
está en condiciones de postularse y por
supuesto que la primera condición es
recibir en canadá para postular a la
ciudadanía claro entonces a quién le
contestamos cuál es su nombre
creo que el nombre es an ya no estoy
seguro si ellas se llama así pero es lo
único que figura aquí en todo caso
traigo un mensaje aquí de noel sosa que
habla sobre el tema una noticia que
hemos escrito sobre san suu kyi dice en
política un día las masas te aclaman en
otro te crucifican en un momento dado
san suu kyi era la mimada de oxiden
y los militares eran los monstruos vamos
a ver en unos cuantos años quién va a
ser el malo en esta película sí porque
parecía que está el líder birmana no
parecía le dieron la ciudadanía
canadiense honorífica y entonces mucha
gente que ahora está diciendo que con la
con la crisis del pueblo rojilla de que
son musulmanes en birmania ella no se ha
comportado a la altura entonces por eso
hay mucha gente que está en contra de su
si es más el tomo la decisión y se bajó
la luz de la foto que la entroniza en el
lugar donde están las personas que
recibieron este seguramente entonces
bueno alguna otra cosita por ahí louis
bueno ya que tengo un mensaje que nos
envía oliver fuentes fuentes dice estoy
muy interesada en saber cuándo llega la
vacuna españa pues en caso de tardar más
de un mes me veo obligada a pedirla a
eeuu un saludo y muchas gracias si se
refiere el tema revolución en el
tratamiento de la migraña yo no sabía ni
siquiera que hay una vacuna contra la
migra imagínate pero hay muchísima gente
que sufre de este mal en todas partes
del mundo
imagino que va a ser un producto en
demanda exactamente yo tengo aquí un
mensaje que nos llegó el nombre es khan
dis
sí
ortiz entonces ella dice qué pasa con
los podcasts no he recibido un nuevo pot
podcast desde el 5 de junio qué pasa con
los podcast pierre le preguntamos a
pierre la semana próxima les de escritos
estamos sus respuestas
así que gracias a cándido ortiz aquí
tengo último y muy cortito mensaje que
dice falta mano de obra en las plantas
pesqueras de atlántico canadiense y
carlos dice me interesa el empleo soy
ciudadano americano bueno como les hemos
dicho siempre cuando hay en generalmente
en los reportajes les damos información
les damos ligas enlaces para que puedan
ir a ver vínculos para que puedan ir a
ver dónde encontrar más información
sobre este tipo de particularidades si
no es inmigración canadá que mantiene
todos los programas en los que se puede
trabajadores viniendo el extranjero para
períodos específicos o empresas
específicas así que ya nos vamos esto
fue todo futuro andina qué rápido pasado
tenemos que extender la duración de una
semana completo en vivo en las américas
en los controles técnicos chantal sanz
suave y también ésta pierde útil
ayudándonos en toda esta transmisión por
youtube y facebook live hasta la próxima
en paloma martínez se despide
[Música]